foreign
Alex is up in San Bernardino California
Alex how can we help
hi hi hi
uh so my goal is to be a DJ I'm 20 years
old I live with my parents and I'm
currently going to college
and I just want to drop out
do you think I should man up and finish
college or do you think I should get a
job move out and rent
okay what would you drop out to do
if you dropped out today what would be
the plan
I've worked at Amazon
for what purpose just to stop going to
class
yeah and just uh what are you pursuing
right what path are you on in college
what major
uh marketing and you've no desire to do
that
not really I'm not really into college
well I get it for school so what's a
full-time what's a full-time DJ Gonna
Make I I don't know and so that's a
serious question what's that what's that
possibility look like
um that's true I turned 21 soon so I'm
gonna try to apply for clubs near my
area but so you don't know
I should look at that yeah okay so
here's the point I don't we don't drop
out of anything into nothing right so I
I totally get that you're not into
college believe me dude I don't have a
degree I couldn't stay in college either
I I get it but to drop out to nothing
just to go to Amazon without knowing
what the plan is let's say you do that
okay you drop out you go work at Amazon
that's honorable you're making money
whatever
okay but you have no idea what a path to
being a successful DJ looks like and
then you look into it and you go oh I I
it's not as uh lucrative or as exciting
as I thought it was once I actually dug
in so now what yeah what I'd rather you
do is sit tight have some discipline
okay and then what I would do is I would
start hanging out with guys that are DJs
I would start you know uh if you got to
work you know behind the bar or
something like that you know
um just to get around DJs you're not
even 21 you probably can't even do that
the point is you get in you get in close
proximity to DJs for real and really
understand like what do you make what do
you make on a weekend because there's a
difference between a DJ and a high-end
Club in South Beach
and the DJ in you know Sheboygan
Wisconsin I mean it's just different
like you want to DJ weddings I mean you
gotta know what you're dealing with so
it's true you gotta know I know Alex
listen if I were you I would I would
stick out College okay I know it's it's
it's a drag yeah just to stick it out no
but when you when you graduate and you
have a college degree you are there is a
marketable sense that he will have if he
wants to go into something else if he
wants to go into business one day or
something like all right it's fair I
think that that's a great I think it's a
I do my point is figure out the future
yeah and and I wouldn't just I would not
I wouldn't drop out right now I want to
know what a path to be next year it
looks like yeah and if it's not
successful what else is out there yeah
but stay put until you figure it out do
you understand what I'm saying
yeah I understand all right there you go
thanks for the call out I need to learn
more about you I was supposed to say
your your knowledge though is sweeping
well I've been to some nice clubs down
in Miami and uh that's a whole different
ball game they're flying these guys and
gals over from Europe